what I'd like us to do before we get to
this new concept that I'm going to show
you I want us to look at all these kinds
of questions that you now know how to
solve you've come a long way now if we
go back to our metaphor it's a little
bit like you now know how to deal with
all different kinds of pieces defending
the king right you can get all of these
guys out of the way I want to show you a
new specific code but it kind of flows
naturally out of the ones you already
know let's think about what kinds of
equations you could write for instance
this one up here right k plus 6 what's
the piece goes with my metaphor here
right what's the piece that's defending
the queue what's keeping us from just
having K by itself yeah it's just that
plus 6 right there's a plus 6 there it
could be a minus 6 or something like
that right so we could add or subtract a
number and that's like a defender have a
look at the next one right what have we
added on to here what extra kind of
piece is there on the left-hand side
yeah yeah what's the for doing can
someone help because it's the right
number but what is the for doing through
the yeah it's multiplication isn't it
right
I could have 4 times 3 I could have paid
divided by 4 right so I've got addition
and subtract
I've got multiple and division of
numbers as well ok but you have a look
at number three right what's going on
here what's different - I have K to that
situation here hmm think carefully how
should she yeah don't let is a yeah I
have so curious well I guess a way I
could say this is in fact you may like
to go back to your original question and
add this on so you can house language
for describing what's happening here
we're adding and we're subtracting
numbers right that's plus 6 years we're
multiplying and dividing by numbers
right you see that like there's 4 out
the front which is multiplication and
therefore this one what we're doing is
we're adding or subtracting not numbers
but pronumerals right like more
or more hours or days or whatever okay
so I'm gonna write pretty rules here all
right now I just want you to carefully
look at what we've just established
right and I've got brackets there but
I'm not gonna worry about him for now
you can add subtract numbers you can
multiply divide numbers you can add
subtract pronumerals if you were trying
to complete the pattern what's the next
step what's missing from this list what
looks like it should be the next thing
yeah multiplying and dividing but not by
notice by printer rules okay what would
happen two equations write an equation
if for instance and this is what you can
write under your new heading if I had
let's go with the letter like say um
let's go with the letter S if I had s
and instead of a d let's subtract the
Apprendi rule what if I multiply by a
plenty room okay now I want to make an
equation I'm trying to do with equation
C right so just as an example I want to
pick out the number 60 because I like
that I'm 16 sweet 16 okay now this is
our example so I'll just write example
at the front we have some language we
already developed some language earlier
this year to write this in a more
concise form
do you remember what language we use
started with an I index form right very
good so s times s I'm multiplying s by
itself twice so I write s squared okay
right now yes okay so we will get to the
names in a second let's just worry about
what it is but yes okay well you have a
look at this equation right this is a
bit strange because you know how before
we said
before we said the goal was to get the
pruning rule plants how to do this the
kind of looks like it's already by
itself right now almost right there's
just this to hang around this just solve
it okay now before I jump to suggestions
I just want you to remember we've been
saying it over again I hope you bit sick
of it really is that the reason why I
equals 21 is a solution and the reason
one is a solution and because -
six-and-a-half and on and on
the reason why they are solutions is
because you can put those numbers where
where can I put them yeah I can do what
I started with
right I could put R equals 21 in here
and it shouldn't work like exit I want
to think of what number can I put in
here for s that would work with this and
it's not because right don't you all
would you put there I would put in four
I would put it for in fact underneath
here let's just write that down right if
you got another car that'd be helpful
for a squared does equal 16 I could pop
it in and it works so s equals four s
equals 4 is a solution okay that's great
but there's something a bit sneaky going
on here right unlike every other
question we've been doing where when you
solve it there's a solution one solution
there's actually another number that I
can put in I can substitute it I can
swap it out for s and it will still work
it will still be a solution can anyone
think of another number that I can
square and give me 16 well if I take
negative 4 right and if I square it
right when you square a negative number
let's just write this out that's minus 4
times minus 4 right what happens to
those negatives
they become positive they cancel each
other out leaving you with sixteen right
sir since -4 squared also equals 16 it
also works for this equation right s can
be both of these it can be two values it
could be one or the other right so I've
got this guy here and this guy here so
the way I write this being that one is
positive four and one is minus 4 I would
say I've run out of space I'll usually
put this underneath and you guys can put
it underneath I would write s equals we
have a symbol for this because it
happened so often plus or minus 4 ok you
might have seen this before actually
well I literally read this as s equals
plus or minus 4 it's kind of like a
shorthand to say two numbers at the same
time but cramming it into the one spot
okay so for instance if I gave you
another one if I said this is a careful
- how about x squared oh how about okay
now every time you see this square thing
happening because of what you noticed
down here there's not just one solution
there are two what's right 100 what
number is it yeah it's 10 it's gonna be
the solution to this is 4 minus 10 and
then put either those numbers in here
and it works yes we'll get on to that we
will it take what time to get to that
but let's just contemplate for a second
let's do example 3 and it's worth
writing down for everyone because it's a
question you will get asked if I said
well I don't know - 25 - 25 now if I
start thinking about all the numbers
that I know about right can you give me
some examples of what families of
numbers do I know about I'll give you an
example first 1 2 3 what would you call
those numbers then the numbers then are
there a couple of names the fancy name
is the natural numbers these numbers
come from counting like why
two three so we call them the counting
numbers right can you take any one of
these numbers and square it to get minus
25 okay now if I try for example not a
counting number but an integer then
they've got negatives right I run into a
problem because this will happen right
the negatives will cancel each other out
I will never get minus 25 even if I try
like weird numbers like saying the young
rational numbers the the fractions like
that you could even try wieder numbers
like the square roots like this right
none of these kinds of numbers will ever
fit this kind of equation okay so
therefore what I write under here and so
should you is I would say no real
solution okay
now you might ask well why why is it
that I say real like why don't you say
no solutions and there is there are
solutions but they aren't what we call
real and we will learn about those in
the future they're being exciting
different kind of maths just like every
time you learn about a different kind of
number it lets you do new kinds of stuff
and that's the same thing with this pen
that's a bit of a spoiler okay yeah okay
you could but then that wouldn't be
squaring would it because by definition
of squaring means take the same number
the same number maybe it's full well
maybe it's negative 4 or maybe it's 10
and you've got to do the same number
twice so otherwise it wouldn't be square
ah that is a great question that's not
what we're looking at today let me just
answer that question after I give us a
heading for this see all of these
equations see how they all look square
in there right these kinds of equations
are called quite reason they're called
ready when you square something how many
sides is a square it's got four like a
quadrangle right like the people say
trango like if a school has a quadrangle
maybe a primary school had a quadrangle
we'll call that a quadrangle squaring
and quadrangle for angled things they
have this so that's why we call these
quadratic equations